un TR s'il vous plaît merci on va passer
au témoin du jour on va revenir sur la
disparition très mystérieuse de lina 15
ans qui reste introuvable depuis samedi
dernier aujourd'hui de nouvelles
informations très inquiétantes ont été
publiées le nouveau détective qui a des
informations que seul on affirme que Tao
le petit ami de l'adolescente aurait
menti sur plusieurs points et aurait
menacé Zoé c'est ça restez avec nous
parce que c'est un truc de fou ce qui
s'est passé c'est que on a eu une jeune
fille qui s'appelait Zoé qui travaillait
avec Lina qui est venu témoigner lundi
et je vous jure que le fait qu'elle soit
venue ça a fait g tu vas nous le
confirmer avancer les choses parce que
en fait le copain on sait pas par ce
qu'il en est encorequ du mais il aurait
euh été il aurait eu des mot très dur
oui envers Zoé et il l'aurait un peu
menacé un peu menacé exaspéré on parler
dans un instant avec Michel Marie c'est
un truc de fou euh et c'est vrai qu'elle
est venue lundi et ça rebondit justement
derrière regardez euh petit recap et
Michel Marie est avec vous c'est
[Musique]
parti la disparition de Lina c'est
l'histoire qui bouleverse les Français
depuis quelques jours jeune fille de 15
ans plus personne n'a de nouvelle d'elle
depuis samedi après-midi plusieurs
pistes sont actuellement à l'étude et
les fouille s'enchaîne pour tenter de
retrouver l'adolescente qui a disparu
alors qu'elle devait rejoindre Tao son
petit ami mais aujourd'hui l'ebdomadaire
le nouveau détective détiendrait des
information exclusive le concernant
alors quelles sont ces nouvelles
révélations Michel Marie qui a longtemps
collaboré avec le nouveau détective est
avec nous ce soir dans
TPMP bon merci Michel d'être avec nous
on va rappeler l'affaire pour les
téléspectateurs N jooig et il y a eu des
choses qui ont rebondit vous allez nous
dire où ça on est mais ça avance et
c'est pas des des des très bonnes
nouvelles hein Gil et Michel et c'est
vrai que la venue de Zoé lundi a fait
rebondir les choses et amener de de
nouveaux éléments pour le moment on va
rappeler l'histoire etécoutez bien
l'histoire parce que c'est c'est vrai
que quand vous nous avez parlé de
l'histoire lundi il y a de trois petites
choses qui ont fait ticker notamment
Jean-Michel et et d'autres personnes qui
étaient chez
eux samedi
23 cette jeune fille Lina quitte son
domicile elle habite à la plaine c'est
un petit hameau un petit village pour se
rendre à la gare de
sainteblaise La Roche où elle doit
prendre le train à 12h03 pour rejoindre
son petit copain Tao qui l'attend à
Strasbourg
elle disparaît sur ce chemin et c'est
d'ailleurs le petit copain fameux Tao
qui va donner le qui va donner l'alerte
qui va signaler à la famille de Lina que
euh Lina n'est pas arrivée à la gare de
Strasbourg et à partir de là la
gendarmerie va engager du personnel pour
faire des recherches on arrive à cibler
à peu près le l'endroit endroit où enfin
à partir de quel endroit elle a disparu
c'est-à-dire entre la gare et une partie
du trajet qu'elle avait déjà fait je
crois qu'il lui restait 900 m à
parcourir pour arriver à la gare et
depuis elle s'est volatilisé de
nombreuses recherches ont été effectués
ils ont les gendarmes ont font sondé
pardon les les deux étants enfin
plusieurs étants ils ont organisé des
batttu et pour l'instant toutes les
recherches sont restées vines alors
justement ça a rebondi euh depuis euh
une équipe de plongeurs de Strasbourg on
réalisé des fouilles dans deux étants
sans rien trouver margaot une ami lina a
dit qu'elle n'était pas comme d'habitude
elle était super contente d'aller à
Strasbourg rejoindre son copain à partir
du moment où elle m'a dit je vais partir
d'un coup je n'ai plus de nouvelles
précises euh c'est ce qu'a dit margaot
d'habitude elle faisait beaucoup de
vocaux pour parler et là d'un coup elle
écrivait très rapidement c'était très
inquiétant et ce n'était pas comme
d'habitude on le sentaé quand elle
parlait c'était très inquiétant parce
qu'elle mettait même des ponctuations
alors que d'habitude elle n'en mettait
pas forcément c'est ce qu'a dit margour
c'est ça une des ce qui sous-entend que
c'est peut-être pas elle qui répondait
et qui utilisait son téléphone
exactement alors vous allez voir comme
ça a rebondi parce que il y a des
éléments qui sont arrivés qui sont quand
même assez troublants selon le point les
les enquêteurs en sont sûr Lina n'a pas
éteint n'a pas atteint l'ét temp du
breux ça c'est sûr donc elle l'a pas
atteint puis il y a une caméra installée
près de ce plan d'eau privé qui
appartient à la société locale de pêche
qui a montré que l'adolescente n'a pas
passé les barrières derrière lesquels se
poursuit la piste cyclable donc ça c'est
un élément déjà on sait Lina aurait donc
disparu sur la route départementable que
vous l'avez dit entre son domicile et
l'entrée de la PIST cyclable ça
représente combien de de de kilomètres
ça j'ai pas la distance exacte il a 2 km
9 entre son domicile et la gare et il
lui restait 900 m à parcourir donc alors
il y a des révélations justement du
nouveau détective vous êtes du nouveau
détective et le nouveau détective a
lâché plusieurs bombes sur leur site et
sur les réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui on
va revenir point par point sur ce qu'ils
ont sorti plusieurs infos qui sèment le
doute sur le profil de Tao le petit ami
de Lina Tao a 19 ans il s'est installé
depuis peu à Strasbourg en tant que
Compagnon du Devoir qu'est-ce que c'est
c'est quoi ça compagnon du devoir c'est
euh je sais pas exactement ce que c'est
c'est j'imagine que c'est
un c'est c'est des artisans artisans de
très haut niveau de très haut niveau
voilà qui par qui parcourent la France
entière compagnonnage voilà arrivé excé
dans leur métier merci Jean-Michel merci
alors il vient de Marseille il s'est mis
en couple avec lina 15 ans depuis début
août début août oui donc c'est c'est
assez récent récent ça fait un peu plus
d'un mois qu'ils sont ensemble et
première info du nouveau détective qui
est assez
troublante on apprend que Tao le petit
ami Lina aurait perdu son téléphone dans
une usine désaffectée en cherchant Lina
l'appareil serait malencontreusement
tombé dans une bouche d'égût alors
racontez-nous ça c'est effectivement qui
ressort de l'enquête de de ma consœur
Sixtine le père euh elle a elle est sur
place elle est toujours sur place et
elle a fait une enquête une bonne
enquête une belle enquête et elle a
retrouvé des témoins et notamment elle a
cette information
euh il aurait participé Tao aurait
participé aux recherches et à l'occasion
de ses recherches il serait monté sur le
toit d'une usine daffecté et alors qu'il
est en haut de ce toit son téléphone
serait tombé malencontreusement dans le
le soupirail dans un soupirail il y a 5
points vous allez voir un qui pose
problème le premier donc c'est la
mystérieuse perte du téléphone Gill
pourquoi le téléphone est essentiel et
sa perte fondamentale c'est important
c'est parce que le petit ami dit qu'il
est parti donc du domicile de la maman
de Lina et chez Lina au matin il va à
Strasbourg il attend à 12h53 à
Strasbourg sur le quai selon lui Lina
elle n'arrive pas et c'est lui qui qui
téléphone à la maman pour lui dire je
suis inquiet Lina n'arrive pas donc ce
téléphone il doit à ce moment-là borner
à
Strasbourg pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a pas
un hasard incroyable une coïncidence qui
fait que alors que on va savoir où borne
ce téléphone et bien lui dit qu'il le
perd donc les enquêteurs encore une fois
il y a pas du tout de il est pas du tout
mis en cause pour le moment mais les
enquêteurs vont vouloir savoir si au
moment où il appelle la maman il est
bien à Strasbourg c'est ça voilà donc
mystérieuse du téléphone c'est le
premier point très très important il y
en a 5 points oui ça le fait que le
téléphone soit tombé n'empêche pas les
services de de police ou de gendarmerie
de de voir le bornage en revanche pardon
en revanche euh on n pas le contenu des
SMS on n pas le contenu de ce qu'ils
disent et c'est ça qui est plus embêtant
si je puis me permettre l'expression
donc le téléphone disparaî on
sait on arrive à retrouver de façon sont
très précises les horaires des échanges
qui appelle qui qui décroche qui
décroche pas et où sont les les
différents protagonistes c'est-à-dire où
se trouve Lina et où se trouve Tao ajé
quelque chose sur ce premier point G il
a C points très importants il y a un
point qui est important quand la
procureure s'est exprimé très rapidement
elle a détaillé les faits et cetera et
elle a dit donc que Tao avait appelé
depuis Strasbourg la maman pour dire que
Lina n'était pas arrivée elle n'a pas
dit verbaam intégral que Tao était sur
le quai de la gare donc pour le moment
pour le moment les enquêteurs comme il y
a de la vidéosurveillance à la gare
Strasbourg vont examiner voir s'il était
bien sur le quai à l'heure qu'il indique
voilà je pense qu'il savà deè deuxème
point très important mais nous il y a
CIN points qui posent problème là autour
de Tao le petit ami de Lina après voilà
pour l'instant il y a rien de fait mais
on va vous donner les 5 points selon une
autre source Tao aurait affirmé avoir
participé à une battue avec un certain
Bryan un ami et visiblement ce serait
faux c'est un mensonge qui a son
importance alors ça c'est c'est c'est
embêtant d'autant que Bryan est très
proche de de Zoe qui est qui est venu
sur ce ce plateau effectivement Tao a
affirmé avoir participé à une battue et
dit qu'il était au côté de Bryan et
Bryan quand il est entendu dit que il
n'a pas de souvenir d'avoir vu
Tao alors ça peut être dans la confusion
dans la maladresse mais ça commence à
faire quand même un c le téléphone qui
dispara potentiel mensong de au 3è point
le jour de sa disparition Lina ne devait
rejoindre Tao que le soir mais au petit
matin changement de plan Tao aurait
appelé la mère de Lina pour lui demander
de la réveiller pour qu'elle prenne le
train et le rejoigne ça c'est un point
c'est incroyable ouais là on comprend
plus hein ça sa fouille
euh il est il habite à Strasbourg il
vient passer la soirée à la plaine en
compagnie donc de de Lina ils passent la
soir ensemble ils dorment ensemble ils
part très tôt T pour un mystérieux
rendez-vous il est convenu qu'il se
retrouve le soir donc elle a toute la
journée pour faire ce qu'elle a à faire
prendre le train et le rejoindre dans la
soirée à Strasbourg et là changement de
programme pour des raisons qui
m'échappent il appelle la maman donc
Fanny la maman de de Lina en lui disant
réveillez votre fille il faut qu'elle
prenne le train il faut qu'elle me
rejoine rapidement à Strasbourg et c'est
ce que la maman va faire elle réveille
sa fille et ensuite c'est comme ça que
la fille va que va prendre la route à
pied la fameuse D350 là pour se rendre à
la gare et elle disparaît sur le sur le
trajet donc on comprend pas pourquoi ce
changement de programme quel est ce
rendez-vous mystérieux à C he enfin qui
l'oblige à partir à 7h du matin et
pourquoi tout modifier à ce il y a
encore deux points qui posent problème
je vais vous les donner dans un instant
Gill par rapport à ce troisème point
j'ai nos confères de ces news qui sont
sur place me disait qu'il y a une quand
même Tao il s'exprimait beaucoup et à
plein de gens il il a dit oh là là ce
weekend on a un programme extrêmement
chargé on a plein de choses à faire et
cetera il détaillait un peu d'une
manière inconsidéré et les gens
comprenaient pas pourquoi tout un
programme de weekend comme si c'était un
programme fondamental alors qu'il y
avait rien de très important donc les
gens se sont dit c'est bizarre de
détailler comme ça un programme pourquoi
est-ce qu'il fait ça voilà 4ème point
qui pose problème et ça nous concerne
euh en apprenant que Zoé la collègue de
Lina allait témoigner dans tes PMP Tapo
Tao lui aurait dit fais gaffe si tu dis
de la
merde et il paraît qu' voilà c'était un
peu chaud qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
c'est exactement ce que vous venez de de
dire
Zoé a révélé que Tao l'avait entre
guillemets pas c'est pas forcément faut
faut voir enfin c'est toujours très
délicat de de de parler pour les autres
mais ça a existé cette il a décroché son
téléphone et il a entre guillemets moi
je prends mes patins je dis qu'il l'a
menacé ou c'est une menace dis dis pas
de la merde fais gaffe c'est une menace
donc cette jeune fille est venue et
courageusement elle a incroyable plus
elle a expliqué son amitié avec avec
Lina avec beaucoup d'émotions elle a
rien dit de elle connaît pas enfin elle
est comme tout le monde elle ne sait pas
ce qui s'est
passé c'est vrai que c'est curieux que
que ce jeune homme alors soit il est
très
maladroit soit il y a autre chose on
voit pas ce qui peut le gêner dans le
oignage si ce n'est si ce n'est que Zoé
elle est là à la sortie du travail à 19h
le vendredi quand la voiture de Tao
vient chercher Lina donc est-ce que lui
se dit elle va dire que j'étais là elle
va préciser des choses est-ce qu'il a
peur de son témoignage est-ce qu'il ne
est-ce qu'il craint que Zoé en dise plus
aux enquêteurs voilà en tout cas cette
agressivité est bizarre aux yeux de tout
le monde non seulement il est pas mis en
cause c'est ça que voulez dire bien
entendu c'est même pas de la présomption
d'innocence c'est qu'il est pas du tout
mis en cause on est bien d'accord
pas garde à vue dans ce dos dans C mê
pas mis en garde à vue tout pas mis en
cause du tout du tout du tout simplement
il y a des faits que l'on expose voilà
voilà selon et 5e point selon le
reporter de nouveau du nouveau détectif
sur place les gendarmes ont quitté
précipitamment le restaurant où il se
trouvaiit suite à après un coup de
téléphone cet après-midi il sont monté
en vitesse dans leur véhicule et ont
quitté les lieux pour retourner sur la
rd350 le chemin sur lequel lina a
disparu euh donc ils se sont c'est un
c'est un truc de fou euh oui euh c'est
ils ont ont eu une info aujourd'hui ils
ont eu une info ils ont été appelés ils
sont partis au girofhare au Deon Girau
euh et a priori ça n'a pas il y a
quelqu'un qui a dit on a l'impression
que les gendarmes font semblant de
continuer les fouilles pour ne pas
trahir le fait qu'ils ont qu'ils ai déjà
un suspect sérieux dans le viseur ou une
voilà une personne c'est possible he
c'est tout à fait possible euh
maintenant euh moi je rappelle quand
même que il y a une série de coïcidence
et qui
cible un individu eu mais ça arrive que
c'est pas la personne aussi mais c'est
pas parce que il y a cette série de
coïncidenence que pour autant ça en fait
uncoupable il a pas été effectivement
placé en garde vu pour l'instant ça il
sera entendu très vraisemblement il a
déjà été entendu mais il sera
probablement réentendu et on verra on
verra bien mais c'est vrai qu'il y a
quand même une série de coïncidences
troublant alors juste ce rebondissement
cet après-midi c'est fou que les gens
qui étaient là-bas ont dit voilà les les
gendarmes se sont précipité comme s'ils
avaient venaent d'avoir une info oui
parce que il y a eu un appel à témoins
qui suscite des dizaines des centaines
de témoignages de gens qui n'ont rien vu
et c'est important aussi parce qu'il ils
ont dit nous on était là et on l'a pas
vu passer à tel endroit donc ils sont en
train de
raccourcir les lieux et de voir à quel
moment elle aurait pu monter dans une
voiture parce que c'est la tessse qui
prédomine pas d'accident la fugue avec
le battage si jamais c'était volontaire
on suppose c'était pas son genre mais
qu'elle se serait manifestée donc elle
est sans doute montée dans une voiture
l'a-t-elle fait volontairement ou
a-t-elle été contrainte et donc il tente
de savoir sur la route où elle aurait
aurait pu monter dans la voiture et de
chercher partout des indices voilà ou
oui parce que ce qui est important c'est
que justement quand elle est montée dans
la voiture si elle est montée dans une
voiture on lui aurait demandé
immédiatement d'éteindre son téléphone
c'est à ce momentlà c'est c'est comme ça
qu'il 11h22 c'est ça ah oui
c'est important
on lui a imposé oui oui soit on lui a
imposé d'éteindre son téléphone soit il
y a une on peut supposer tout ce qu'on
veut il y a une contrainte exactement
cont merci en tout cas Michel est-ce que
vous avez d'autres chose à ajouter non
non pour revenir au départ précipité des
gendarmes vu par notre porter dans un
restaurant je crois ça arrive souvent
sur les gros fait divers qui il y a une
vraie tension et un coup de chield de
l'étatmajor un coup de du patron on sent
en tout cas que l'enquête avance voilà
et et il mettentenqute avance qu'on
avait dit la dernière fois sur et le
lendemain il y a eu le le dénouement
nous ce qu'on aimerait c'est qu' on
retrouve Lina vivante et que sa mère la
retrouve vivante parce que elle vit des
moments très très compliqués on pense
fort à sa maman vraiment je me mets à sa
place et pense à elle tous les jours en
tout cas et voilà il faut qu'elle reste
forte et qu'elle garde espoir merci à
vous tout de suite l'émission